As we mentioned previously, in journal, the editors may lie in the knowledge,
in the reasoning, or the architecture of a nation. And therefore, learning and
correcting errors might be applicable to any one of those.
However, in this lesson, we will be focusing only on errors and
knowledge. In fact, in particular, we'll be focusing on errors and
classification knowledge. Classification, of course,
is a topic that we have considered this class repeatedly. Let us
consider an air agent that has two examples of executing an action in the world.
In the first experience, the agent will use this object as a cup and
gets the feedback, this indeed was a cup. So this was a positive experience.
This, on the other hand, is a negative example. Here, the agent viewed this as
a cup and got the feedback that this should not have been viewed as a cup.
We can visualize the problem of identifying what knowledge element led the agent
to incorrectly classify this as a cup. As follows. This left circle here consist
of all features that describe the positive example. The circle on the right
consist of all features that describe the negative example. So features in this
left circle might be things like this is a handle, there is a question mark,
there is a blue interior and so on. The circle on the right consist of features.
That characterize a negative example. It has a movable handle.
It has a red interior. It has red and white markings on the outside.
There's some features that characterize only the positive experience and
not the negative experience. There are those that characterize only,
the negative experience, and not the positive experience.
There are also many features that characterize both the positive and
the negative example. For example they are both concave, they both have handles,
and so on. In this example, it is these features that are specially important.
We'll call them fault suspicious features. We call them fault suspicious
features because first they identify only the negative experience. Secondly,
one or more of these features may be responsible for the fact that the agent
classified this as a positive example when in fact it was a negative example.
As an example suppose that this features corresponds to a movable handle. This
is a false suspicious feature. It is false because this experience was false.
It is suspicious because it does not characterize the positive experience.
And thus it may be one of the features responsible for the fact that this was
a negative example. But now there's an additional problem. There are number
of false suspicious features here. So how will the agent decide which false
suspicious feature to focus on? We've encountered this problem earlier,
when we were talking about incremental costs of learning. At that point we had
said that we wanted to give examples in an order, such that each succeeding
example referred to the current constant definition, and exactly one feature.
So that the agent knows exactly what the focus that feature is on.
The same kind of problem occurs again how might the agent know which feature to
focus on. One possible idea is that it could try on of the feature at a time and
see if it will work. That is it could select this feature to repeat the process
get more feedback and either is accepted or eliminated. An alternate method is
that the agent perceived not just two experiences. But many such experiences. So
there were other positive experiences that covered this part of the circle.
That would leave only this as a false suspicious feature, and then the agent can
focus attention on this feature. As an example, just like this circle may
correspond to a movable handle, this may correspond to red interior. Because red
interior is one of the features that characterizes a negative example and
not a positive example. But later on, there might be another positive example
that comes of a cup, which had a red interior in which case agent can
exclude this particular feature. The reverse of this situation is also possible.
Let us suppose that the agent decides that this is not a cup,
perhaps because its definition says that something with a blue interior is
not a cup. And therefore, it doesn't bring water to you inside this cup and
tells you there is no cup available in the kitchen. You go to the kitchen.
You see it and you say, well, this is the cup. Now, the agent must learn
why did they decide that it was not a cup. In this case, the relevant features
are these three features. These are the three features that define this cup, but
do not define the other experiences. So this dot may correspond to a blue
interior, this dot may correspond to a question mark on the exterior, we'll call
this feature true suspicious, just like we call them false suspicious.
These are the features that prevented the agent from deciding that this was
a positive example of a cup. One or more of these features may be
responsible for the agent's failure to recognize that this was a cup